[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages coming up then we'll see
what's making the headlines
with the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire
and the parliamentary sketch writer and
columnist for the telegraph modeling
grand
first hours ever let's check out the
front pages the daily mail leading with
a report from one of its journalists who
is on board hms defender
as russian warplanes and vessels
targeted the royal navy warship
in the black sea berlin and paris
proposed a reset
for eu relations with moscow the
financial times reports that
germany and france have called for
closer eu engagement with russia
the metro meanwhile reports on the
conviction of a police officer for
killing former footballer dalian
atkinson
the family of mr atkinson have described
their pain
and relief after a five-year fight for
justice that's the lead for
the guardian
the telegraph goes with german
chancellor angela merkel demanding eu
countries introduce
mandatory quarantine for britons wanting
to holiday
in europe this summer the health sector
matt hancock faces a major battle
to pass a law handing him new powers
over the nhs according to the eye
the delhi mirror dedicates its front
page to people in the uk who have
carried out random acts of kindness
over the past couple of years with the
headline thank you
so kevin mcguire and madeline grant are
here um
journalists on this boat did that uh
help decide what happened do you think
or i'm being
very cynical about this kevin this uh
this warship
well i think it did and the problem for
the british government the royal navy
is uh they are cr um basically
contradicting
what the what the mod said which was
essentially nothing happened because if
you look at the daily mail report
from mark nichol the defense editor he
talks about
crouching either side of the bridge
as russian warplanes
repeated bursts of cannon fire and the
crew
frantically putting on flame retardant
suits and
body armor well that's that's very
different to the
royal navy account which uh through the
mod which is essentially
going through territorial waters there
was a couple of small russian ships
uh some uh firing far
in the distance which was pre-planned
and
the planes are acknowledged so
he's not the only uh correspondent mark
nichol the bbc's correspondent has also
finally reported you can hear the planes
and he seems to have
you know thought it was was bigger than
the mod
downing street in the uk government says
not quite the full
russian account but i think the uh the
uk account is called into question
uh crimea is obviously disputed um you
might say these waters are disputed
although
the british navy doesn't think so who's
needling who here madeleine
it's very hard to tell as always with
russia i mean there's
it's it's i think the mistake that that
we make is to sort of take anything that
they
say or do at face value i mean there's
various interpretations of what happens
i i mean i think as kevin says
the account in the daily mail sounds
extremely vivid talk of
hour-long cannon fire and you know
massive concern aboard ship which does
seem
a lot more friendly than the rather
neutral account that the mod gave
earlier today
but i mean there's there's many
possibilities here it's possible that
russia is testing the uk and nato to see
how they respond
it's possible that they're playing uh
which is what uh the chairman of the
foreign affairs select committee tom
tugan had alluded to earlier today uh
sort of
he referred to potemkin style sabre
rattling playing games perhaps to
bolster support domestically you know
there are numerous possibilities but i
think that
the difficulty is trying to reason with
what russia was doing and try to kind of
deal with them as if you're dealing with
a
a reasonable um opponent that will
behave in a rational way
yes and as if the timing couldn't be
worse if we go to the ft
um they're reporting that germany and
france have called for closer eu
engagement with russia
to build on discussions with moscow in
the wake of uh
u.s president joe biden's geneva summit
with with vladimir putin
you know is he is is he friend or foe
kevin
uh putin regularly germany relies
on russia for a lot of its energy she
has a vested interest
in closer relations arguably um
we all have a vested interest in at
least talking and trying to get along
but you
you can't just ignore the human rights
violations
in russia you can't ignore uh
the threats around the world from from
russia but it is better to talk as
biden decided when he held that uh
summit last week with
with putin but it's interesting though
you read that ft account
merkel seems to have got macron involved
the italians may be
involved too um but with the european
union
while merkel and the others may want a
closer relationship the baltic states
uh estonia lithuania and latvia
uh and poland for instance which were
part of the
soviet union not very long ago which was
dominated by
russia they're rather rather concerned
so there will be big pressures in the
european union but i think biden has
just made that that move
which will look for a reset um but you
know here in the uk
we'll remember the salisbury poisonings
uh and of course crimea itself the
annexation
and also the destabilization of ukraine
on its border with uh with russia
they're not going to go away they're
still big big issues although
in truth the annexation of the crimea
which was predominantly russian speaking
uh and was only moved into ukraine i
think in the 1950s uh by the soviet
union as an administrator
who i think russia is never going to
give that up it's going to be a running
sword it's going to be very difficult
for you
ukraine is going to be very difficult
for other other countries but
it's just not it's just not going to
happen you just cannot see now how
russia
will ever withdraw from crimea he can't
force him to do it
militarily and i don't think it would
work economically and
diplomatically either well let's move on
but uh
talking of germany let's go to the front
page of the daily telegraph
uh which is that the german chancellor
has suggested
that all uk citizens who arrive in
eu states should be forced to quarantine
now this scuppers many a hope of a
holiday
should the british government change
their mind madeleine on letting people
go to ambulance countries and not
quarantining back here
god i mean it's a it's a it's a curious
it's a curious row isn't it i mean i
don't remember
angela merkel quarantining herself when
she arrived for the g7 conference a
couple of weeks ago
um i mean sorry anna your question was
about
um what what we should do with with our
tourists whether we should change our
guidance yet
i mean i guess it's too early to say if
this is actually going ahead
because although angela merkel has um
has
called for it it's not yet policy and
it's likely to create
or at least it's not yet eu wide policy
and it's likely to create
considerable disagreement within the
schengen zone because countries like
spain and greece rely heavily on uk
tourism
and they're going to be very reluctant
to impose these sorts of measures and
they can't be forced to by
the eu um so i think it's a little early
to say whether whether we should
change our guidance to reflect this um
this latest
um statement from angela merkel yes and
uh two issues they say here
new eu-wide rules will be introduced
next week
to facilitate the resumption of travel
which will allow vaccinated people to
move freely within the schengen area
and here in the uk they suggest merkel's
intervention coming
ahead of a key meeting at which
ministers are expected to approve plans
for fully vaccinated citizens
to be able to travel to ambulance
countries so what what when is this
meeting
kevin and what is likely to be we
decided
well we should we should get a decision
tomorrow on which which countries will
move if any at all and green amber and
and red there will be an announcement
there's been a lot of speculation that's
uh
certainly the the islands of greece and
spain which are very low rates
uh may may actually be opened up and put
on the green list and
not entire countries but uh there's a
lot of speculation you never quite know
until you get the decision because the
the way these uh
calls are made is shrouded in mystery
and i think there's a lot of politics
uh involved in it and whether whether
the government thinks you could open up
someone not others and
what messages does that send but uh
angela merkel certainly putting trying
to put a
spammer in the works there i think she i
think she would lose out in the european
union because madeleine said
spain and greece are desperate to have
british tourists
uh visiting as our portugal malta and a
number of the other countries but
you could you can see now when we're
edging towards opening up and maybe
maybe we'll have to wait until the july
19th uh announcement on what the future
of uh restrictions in england from boris
johnson
to see what happens with holiday plans
because there have been reports of a
dispute with some ministers want to open
and open up in july
others want to hold back until all this
but
i feel when you look at the opinion
polls the majority of uh people seem to
to put uh defeating the virus above
going back on holiday but when we saw
those figures that
so few people who've been going to amber
countries when they come back
have tested positive it's a tiny tiny
number you might be you might be more at
risk now going off to
blackburn or bolton than you would be to
parts of
resource space and it's going to get
harder and harder to keep that
all those restrictions on travel and we
saw the protests in london
uh today from people in the travel
industry it's a huge industry a lot of
jobs a lot of value there so
it's not just about people wanting to go
on holiday it's also about a key part of
the economy
yeah i think they said 195 000 jobs
didn't they and many of them
operating with 10 of their income but
having to not follow their staff because
they're constantly having to change
their customers plans so they have
neither furlough nor income
which is absolutely devastating for them
um but yes you're right the day of
protests uh many people saying
why are we quibbling about sending
people to countries with lower rates
than ours
you know it's europe that doesn't want
the delta variant uh which takes us to
the ft as well madeleine on a
you know a related issue uh which is the
sort of hypocrisy of allowing all these
vips fans
to to come to wembley uh when travel is
effectively on hold for so many people
yeah absolutely this is i think rather
like the g7 conference caused a lot of
people to feel
aggrieved at the way that they could see
the rules being flattered by
by the big dogs um this news about the
special rules for
ua for vips is precisely the thing
that's going to spark
disenchantment it's uh that this was
actually a key issue that many of the
people at the protest outside parliament
the representatives of the travel
industry the point that
they were making there um and i i think
after
it's it's a kind of ever since the the
barnard castle incident
um there's been there's been a real
sense of and i think it is often
underestimated by politicians who need
to think more carefully about how things
look and
seem to the public who you know have
been putting up with these restrictions
for a very very long time
um it cuts through in a way that idea of
one rule for us another for them
uh really annoys people in a way that i
think sometimes the politicians are a
bit surprised by
yeah the g7 beach party was one of those
as well for some people i know um
madeleine kevin stay there lots more
still to come in coding more on the
first
face-to-face meeting between the prime
minister and the monarch in more than a
year
more on that to come
[Music]